so we spoke earlier in the show about
joe biden warning russian president
vladimir putin don't invade ukraine if
you do it we're going to put in place
economic sanctions you're not going to
like it don't do it well tucker carlson
doesn't like it he doesn't like what joe
biden is saying
last night fox news propagandist tucker
carlson
sided with russia and with vladimir
putin saying the president
of russia
just wants to keep his western borders
secure now i already told you earlier
that russia has been massing troops at
the border with ukraine the idea being
they're either gauging what the reaction
would be to a potential invasion or
they're actually planning an invasion of
ukraine and joe biden went to putin
yesterday and said don't invade ukraine
we will punish you economically if you
do
tucker
went on a 14-minute rant last night
defending russia's actions saying it's
biden who should be careful because next
thing you know he might start a war if
he threatens putin so there are so many
things here to talk about let's first
look at a couple of clips here is tucker
accurately saying you know
the risk to iowans
from putin and russia is very low and
tucker is absolutely right about that
we're gonna freeze germany and
luxembourg and that's going to teach
vladimir putin again what you just saw
there is a child who has no idea what
she's talking about but keeps talking
anyway we will defend ukraine says joni
ernst
remember this is a senator from iowa so
what happens if we don't defend ukraine
joni ernst will kids in des moines grow
up to speak russian
no one asked her that question she's
never thought about it for a moment
that all this reading from the same
talking points from adam schiff to roger
wicker to joni ernst great okay so i
mean tucker's right he's condescending
he's pathetic he's a propagandist but
he's right the the russia thing
is not a risk to kids in iowa where joni
ernst is a senator and i wish that that
had been the perspective so many more
times in american history when we were
doing military engagements iraq comes to
mind as one example but we aren't
talking about military intervention here
at least not right now nor do i support
one what we're talking about here is
economic sanctions
and
participating in the shared defense of
ukraine so tucker continues we're going
to kind of go back
to what he said before the clip we just
watched take a look but what's so
interesting and ought to make you sit up
and pay attention is suddenly partisan
republicans are making identical noises
just this afternoon senator roger wicker
of mississippi not a genius famously but
still a sitting republican center
went on fox news to say we may need to
send american troops to ukraine and
possibly because this isn't insane or
anything
think about the use of nuclear weapons
got that in our back pocket nuclear
weapons
roger wicker sitting u.s senator
no one in washington laughed at roger
wicker
this is so crazy that no one seems aware
of how crazy it is they're all just
sitting back and listening to tori and
newland
tell them
what we need to do
how much has this penetrated the psyche
of washington dc well here's a sad piece
of tape this is joni ernst who's totally
affable nice republican sort of
reasonable in most things from the
midwest suddenly sounding like a
bloodthirsty warmonger something like
actually adam schiff when she talks
about that dastardly vladimir putin
he needs to say to vladimir putin
that we are no longer going to allow you
to to continue with the nordstream 2
pipeline we need you to know and
understand that we will defend ukraine
and we will provide them assistance he
needs to make that very clear
putin is so bad we're going to cut off
natural gas to western europe
in retaliation against him in december
we're going to freeze germany and
luxembourg and that's gonna teach
vladimir putin again what you just saw
there is a child who has no idea what
she's talking about but keeps talking
anyway okay so then we get to like the
part about joni ernst that i played for
you earlier
so
here's the deal with this
your reaction might be
republicans just love russia
so of course tucker is siding with
russia and it is true
that increasingly under trump
these republicans are
more and more sort of smitten
by these authoritarian strong men and
russia is is you know one example of
that but this is actually bigger than
that and remember i don't want war with
russia i didn't want trump going to war
with russia i don't want joe biden going
to war with russia i'm not calling for
war with russia at all period
what i want to point out to you
is that for republicans
the principle
is that democrats are always in the
wrong
under obama the focus was
beta obama
let putin take crimea
and he just let him do it he walked all
over obama once again why didn't obama
go to war why didn't obama deploy troops
why did obama let putin do whatever the
hell he wanted
income donald trump
the focus then became
why wouldn't we want to get along with
poot
getting along is good you know their
voices would go up three out putin
didn't do anything wrong
let's be friends trump is right not to
go after putin trump is right not to
treat putin
uh uh strongly and instead treats him
with kid gloves you warmongering
liberals stop saying trump should be
going aggressive with putin and then now
it's joe biden and now it's well
even merely threatening economic
sanctions is crazy putin's not that bad
putin's just protecting his border well
but hold on a second guys
under obama you flipped out because
obama didn't stop putin from taking
crimea
now biden is bad for doing something at
least an economic threat i thought
wasn't this what you said obama was
wrong for not doing and now biden is
wrong for doing it and at the end of the
day
these people are truly pathetic because
there are no underlying values or
principles with foreign policy
the only underlying principle is attack
democrats the principle is
it's always the fault of some democrat
doing something wrong either democrats
did the wrong thing
by doing something or democrats did the
wrong thing by not doing something or
democrats wanted the republican to do
the wrong thing but fortunately the
republican was smart and strong and wise
enough not to do it under obama obama
was that democrat
under trump it was other democrats
saying
why is trump treating putin like this
and not taking him seriously and then
under biden it goes back to being joe
biden this is amazing even for tucker
the defense of putin here but at this
point i probably shouldn't even really
be that surprised
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door ready to eat no
cooking no cleaning dishes saves you a
lot of time you can choose from over 50
hot and cold meal options there's
smoothies grain and noodle bowls soups
i'm a big soup guy many of you know that
i also really liked the vegan meatballs
with marinara noodles delicious
both eye and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save 35 dollars when you go to
splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below